We're
moving on to,
to have and have not.
Um,
and this novel was
written in a fairly have,
has it fashion.
It was written in 19,
between 1935 and 1937 basically,
um, it was written when Hemingway was
taking a break from his coverage of the
Spanish civil war,
so he would be in Spain for Spanish
civil war and then he would, um,
come back, um, to the, uh, United
States, but after they, um,
also to The Bahamas to right
to have and have not. So, uh,
we'll be reading, you guys know that we'll
be reading for whom the bell tolls, um,
for whom the bell tolls and have and
have not really interlocking in multiple
ways because one is balanced pencil awards
and this one's written when Hemingway
was covering the span.
So awards.
So we can really think of those as in
dialogue in really interesting ways.
Um,
the um,
hotel that Hemingway's stayed at,
uh,
when he was writing to have and have not,
was in The Bahamas is in the
mini is the conceit Anglo hotel.
Actually, I'm the hotel burned
down, so it's no longer there.
But this was a picture taken before that
was really lucky that there was this
picture. Um, and inside of
there, there's a plaque standard.
This was the home of Ernest Hemingway.
Um, he was there for two years,
um, the police road to have and have
not in various different places,
but this was one of the main places
he stayed at when he wrote the novel.
Um, as we also know, Cuba, um,
was very important to Hemingway. Um,
this is, uh, his house is still standing.
The thing that they're here,
um, which is now than Lucio. Um,
on this Hemingway in Havana.
Um,
and this is a picture
of Hemingway writing.
He wrote the man,
Oh man in the sea when he was
in Cuba in this very house.
Roy's books were there. So, um,
but this was Polly picture was polytech
and a little later in the 1950s,
um,
so I found some pictures of
Havana in the 1930 business.
The while the frame, this
is the El Malecon, uh,
with the sea war.
You can see are there some really
very magnificent buildings, uh,
on the Wallace van.
And this is the main avenue,
the Anita, those president is
very, very impressive looking.
Um,
avenue.
Cuba was actually called the Paris of
the Western in the first half of the 20th
century. And we can see why, uh, it
really was a very magnificent place.
And, um, this is downtown Havana
and still in the thirties. Um,
and this is bothered
Hemingway went to quill,
has the sloppy joes but are,
and here's a picture of him
and the British playwright,
no coward at the sloppy Joes Ball. So, um,
really interesting historic
pictures other than drinking.
Hemingway also went fishing a lot as we
can see as a very intimate knowledge of,
of fishing. And the fish
that especially, uh,
preoccupy him was the mall.
And so this is a description
from to have and have not, um,
of what Amal and look like. And I just
happened to have found this picture,
the single correspondence lag
way through that, the thought,
the eye and open lower jaw and huge
purple black head of a black Marlin from
this picture.
We can't really see how big areas.
This is a picture of Hemingway
on the boat and Nida, um,
this is just before he wrote to have
and have not, um, with his friends.
Um, and the next picture is, um,
taken in the mini,
um,
and with his second wife
Pauline and his three sons,
Gregory, John and Patrick, 19 than five.
And we can see just how
huge a tamale in is.
It could weigh up to a
thousand partners. So, um, the,
this picture is, I downloaded, um,
online things to the Ernest Hemingway
collection at the JFK Library in Boston.
So this is just to acknowledge
a very important collection. Um,
if you guys want to do future work on
him anyway, that's the place to go,
um, is helpful, um, in thinking
about to have and have not,
um,
to think a little bit about the
publication district of this novel.
It was also publish as short stories.
It's too short stories.
Um,
one trip across was published
in a cosmopolitan 1934.
Um,
and then the traders return publish and
as wired magazine 1936 and then to have
and have not was published
by a Scribner's in 1937. Um,
so,
um,
because of the way it came out
initially as she was stories,
I think once again we have to think about
the narrative structure of the novel
and this a lot to think about because
it turns out that this is an incredibly
complicated switching back and forth
between the first person and third person.
So one is told and the first
person is themes for straight,
straightforward is told from herring.
Morgan's point of view is also the spring,
the session cause spraying.
So, um, it is in many ways the
spring and Harry Morgan's life.
Um,
and then part two is toe
and the third person.
Um,
and this is actually quite Jordan.
All of a sudden we see Harry
more than from the outside. Um,
as we knew nothing about him,
his reintroduced to us as
he and even as the man,
the very,
very alienating perspective and part
you and as the section called the fall.
And then part three is called a winter.
And here is even more complicated than
that is mixed narration begins with
someone who's not even a very important
character of someone called [inaudible]
who tells the story in chat tonight.
Um,
and then it switches back
to Harry and chapter 10.
And then we get third person narration
for a good part of the part two,
a part three. And then the
very final chapter, Chapter 26,
it switches back to the first person
narration, but there's Toba and Marie,
Harry's wife.
Um,
so at the very least we can say that
Hemingway's experimented with all kinds of
narrative who of views.
Um,
and so the most fundamental question,
um,
has to do with pronouns. Um, who
is attached to which pronoun?
Why does having way,
uh,
choose to use certain pronouns while the
see choose to use some points of views
for that section.
Um,
and this is also a good moment to start
thinking about the interconnections,
Amanda Novels. I know that you guys
just turn in your first paper, so,
but there's not too early to start
thinking about the next big project.
Um,
and the interconnections amount of novels
would be a very good approach to thing
about that larger project. So, um,
two things are very clear in terms
of the prior publication as she was
[inaudible] to have and have not
obviously looks back to in our time.
There seems to be Hemingway's habit
is to publish publish poets as short
stories. Actually it's very common, uh,
publish pause and short stories and
then to have a more, a larger entity,
um, whether or not, um,
the two are related in terms of this
kind of pry publication history is a good
question. Um, but to have and
have not, it's also linked,
um,
to the sound and the theory because
of the multiple narratives voices,
um, in the sound of the fury, we
know that they are just four, right?
So the three brothers, um, each guest
one section and then the ignition,
a narration in section four and to have
and have not is much less clear cut than
that.
As I just mentioned,
someone who's quite Mojito to a story
like Alvin guests to have a section.
So he obviously doesn't have to send
challenged that Benji or Quentin or Jason.
Um, there's the three brothers
do in, in Santa Theory. Uh,
why does someone like Albert get
to tell the story? Um, it's um,
even though the two novels have share
common ground in terms of multiple
narrative whizzes, the actual
configuration of those voices, um,
the two different configurations
in the two novels. Um,
and finally something new is also
emerging and to half and half,
not that we haven't seen so far or that
hasn't been in the foreground a up to
this point. Then I like to call your
attention to add, which as characters,
as generic types with classification,
with taxonomy of social types,
we see it in the very title of
the novel is divided into two,
the haves and the have nots.
Um,
and obviously to social
types. Um, it's very much, um,
kind of organizing
principle in this novel. Uh,
but it also looks forward
to the Fitzgerald stories
that we'll be reading next
week.
A story like the ritual boy is very
much about this kind of classifiable and
generic type.
Um,
so, um, I wanted to think about this. Um,
one of the thing about the
difference between two novels, um,
in terms of another novel that,
um, that Hemingway is famous for,
which is the old man and the sea.
Um,
and um,
they're both sat in Cuba,
the above about Cuba for some extent,
but no central league about
Cuba but standing Cuba, uh,
but in many ways they represent two
different sides of the spectrum, um,
to have and have not,
um,
is as we can see from the
Tido is a divided canvas is
populated by two taxonomic
groups. Um, so it's very
much about classify ability.
Not only is it giving
us two taxonomic groups,
but it's also about the phenomenon
of classify ability. Um,
are human beings classify,
can they be put under
various generic labels?
That is a big question in
his novel to the old man.
And the sea is in many ways on
the other side of the spectrum,
as we can see as you,
as you guys know the story,
the novel is about a solitary,
um,
fishermen, Cuban fishermen
in San Diego. Um,
and his decision to go out along,
um,
and he did get this huge Marlin
once again, that fish, um,
and he's trying to save that, uh,
from being eaten up by sharks.
So the novel was really about his struggle
against the sharks and he loses out
of the mountain is completely cleaned out
by the sharks by the end of the novel.
Uh,
but in spite of that ending,
it is really about the heroic struggle
of man against elemental forces.
So, um, most of us know Hemingway
actually as the Hemingway,
the old man and the sea, and it's, um,
helpful to keep that in mind.
But Hemingway is also very interested
in the other side of the equation,
which is about, um, not
so much about individuals,
as about individuals who can be
understood or can be encompass,
accounted for in terms
of social types. So, um,
we see it not only in the
main characters in the novel,
but also in very marginal characters.
People who would appear just once.
Um, they also presented to us as social
types. So the very opening of the novel,
um,
Harry Morgan is approached by his three
young Cubans who want to pay him a lot
of money to be taken to the United States.
Um, and this is how they are described.
They were good looking young
fellows work good clothes,
none of them wore hats and they
look like they had plenty of money.
They talk friendly with money anyway.
And there's the kind of English
Cubans with money speed,
right.
So obviously classify as well it's
fun standard and this passage,
um,
the various syntax they talked plenty of
money is an expression that we use and
is certainly, it's the kind of labeling
that goes on behind that kind of syntax.
Um, so the uh, where the
parent is the clothes,
the speech patterns of these
people easily classify them.
We don't really need to know much else
about them that they haven't weighed,
is not interested in telling
as much else about them.
They are just there as representatives
of Cubans with money who need to get out
of Cuba at that moment.
Um,
but because classifiable it
seems so central to the novel.
The question,
obviously it arises as to whether or not
Harry Morgan himself as classifiable,
he is a hero.
He's a protagonist who inhabits a novel
that is populated by loss of social
types, right? Whether or not
he belongs with Nahu fist,
completely into that landscape
is to open question. Um,
is he evil,
uh,
to break away okayso finally
from that landscape does,
he's managed to stand out
and be an individual that
we would recognize and that
will stick in our memories as one
individual rather than as one social type.
That is the question that we have to think
about and I like to break that down a
little bit. Um, in terms of for, uh,
interconnected clusters
of issues, one is, um,
to willy stands,
Harry Morgan,
a racist is he races or not races?
Um,
the other question and that's something
that we've already seen in thought the
play approved now,
um,
and that is highlighted
dramatize by Hemingway's joys
and narrative technique is
whether he is an eye or whether he is
a he and the choice of those pronouns.
Obviously it has narrative
implications, right? If he is an iron,
very likely we're going to see the inside
of him is going to be an interior view
of Harriet.
If he's going to be a here,
very likely there's going to be
an external view of Paris. Um,
just as in [inaudible] there's an external
view and not very pretty view of doc
in the false section of
the sound, the theory. Um,
and finally going back to the title of
the course of the, of the novel, uh,
whether he is a half or have not,
does he accept the novel empty handed?
Um,
can you say that he has
achieved something? Um,
there's something is in his
possession that he has on there.
He owns something with he also
both in the beginning, uh,
whether he's still almost anything at
all at the annals of novel. That is no,
the question,
um,
I raised the question of racism because
that is the question raised by Toni
Morrison.
Toni Morrison,
we know as the author of novels
[inaudible] live in aisles like beloved.
Um, but she's also, um, uh, someone who,
um,
gives a lot of talks and she also
turned some of those tasks into essays.
So play in the dark is the collection
of essays published by Tony Morrison.
And she devoted the long section
to Hemingway and to have,
to have and have not,
it's very interesting that this is not
the best known novel I haven't went,
but this is the novel that,
um, Morrison singles out. Um,
or those just singling it
out, not to praise it. Uh,
I've had to pull into some troubling
aspects of to have and have not,
um,
and this is what Morrison says.
Harry includes a nigger and his crew,
a a man who threw out all of that.
One has known name,
his appearance is taken
on by the sentence.
Just then the nigger we had
getting paid comes down to dark.
The black man is not only
nameless for five chapters,
he's not even hired.
Just someone we had getting
beat the kind of trend with.
Now that Asian assessing the job and
then she goes on to say the spatial and
conceptual difference is marked by the
shortcut that the term nigger allows with
all this color and cast implications.
The term occupies a territory
between man and animal for free.
Um, strong objections to the novel. Um,
in response, I'll just, not to
defend him in way completely,
but just to point out that the one that
goes up use my Faulkner's we've just
seen,
um,
is also used by Marc train because that's
the word that those characters were
the views how Finn with have used
the neighbor in the 19th century.
It would have been very odd for Mark
Twain not to use that work in this novel.
Um,
someone like Quentin,
suddenly Jason would have used the
word nigger if they were living people.
So it would have been very odd for farming
not to use that work because that's
the basic speech pattern
of his characters. Um,
but quite aside from that,
um,
but as you also point out
that, um, Maura's and Ashley,
you can see it's that it's only
in part one that this black man,
um, doesn't have a name. He actually,
he does over there in part two.
So we can look at that
moment of transition when the
black men acquires and name
off son, find out what his car. Um,
but uh, before we get into part two,
I just want to actually look at
another one to call attention to,
um,
a passage where the word nigger is used.
But now to describe the black
men that Morrison has in mind.
This is an earlier appearance
of that word nigger. Um,
and this is actually coming right after,
um,
Harry's conversation with
those three, uh, rich Cubans.
Um, all of a sudden this,
this seat is fighting,
breaking out and shooting.
Um,
and it turns out that the key player
in that shooting as a black character,
the nigger with a Tommy gun goddess
phase almost into the street and gave the
back of the wagon of births from
underneath. And sure enough,
one came down,
fall into what the sidewalk with his
head above the curb attended feet.
The leaker charlatan in the
belly with a Tommy Gun with one.
Must've been the last shot in it
because I saw him throw it down.
No Pancho set down hard
and went over four with,
he was trying to come up,
still holding onto the Luger,
only he couldn't get his head up when
a nigger and took the shotgun that was
lying again as the wheel of the car by
the show for and to do the side of his
head, some nigger. Okay.
So we might object to file
and of this theme. Uh,
but what is clear in this passage is the
tremendous admiration that having wet
has for this black character he's been
meant to kill to his job is to kill the
three rich Cubans.
Um,
and he accomplishes that
task magnificently. Um,
so this is,
and having way is just using every bit
of his writerly skill to convey to us,
even those of us who really know nothing
about guns and nothing about the odd of
shooting.
To highlight for us,
one an odd there's there is to be able
to get your face almost down to the
street until he will to get someone,
um,
to get the shotgun when there's no more,
nothing left in your own.
Tommi Gunn. And to be able to finish
off the last of the three Cubans,
one against three, um, you know,
just the performance of it.
Um,
so this nothing but admiration in this
description of the black man and we can
almost get a kind of a capsule summary
of the intense admiration from the two
word phrase that concludes the
passage. Some nigger, okay.
How many ways,
still using the word nigger,
but the expression Stum Negro almost
completely undermines that word.
Yes,
he's a nigger.
His the classifiable type,
but he's Nivison specimen.
He's an amazing specimen of that type.
So much so that his stretching
that type two is limit.
So much so that he's almost making
that type non anthology. No,
he's such an amazing character
that is almost, you know,
you can call him a nigger, but it doesn't
really mean anything, was some nigger.
Um,
it turns out that some that construction,
some followed by what appears
to be a derogatory term,
that is a kind of a verbal
tick for Harry Morgan.
He uses that phrase over and over
again for other characters as well.
So we can go and look at some other
instances when he uses that construction.
Um,
and it turns out that he also
uses it for the man who has a,
who owes him $825. And they said it
was a clear out without paying a cent.
This is the very regionals to Johnson who
charters the boat for fishing managers
to lose the whole, um, other, um, um, the,
the, um, the works under on boat, um,
managers to, to, um, uh,
to do real damage, uh, to, to, to,
to Harry's bill because of his
enamel as efficient and um,
and so he owes $825.
And this Mr. Johnson,
even though he is quite in as a fisherman,
he nonetheless is very
skilled in one thing.
And this is why this passage pays
tribute to he went on the plane,
frankly, he frankly said,
all right, there was,
the counselor was close as
well, the science. And anyhow,
Wayne was in Miami by now.
I couldn't even send a wire
some Mr. Johnson, right.
It was my fault.
I should have known better how I didn't
even have enough money to put in gas.
It was a hell of a note.
All right, so Mr. Johnson,
it is not the same kind of
performance as the shooting,
but it guests from Harry the
same involuntary and the regime,
even though he's obviously the victim
of that magnificent performance on the
poem, Mr. Johnson, it takes nerve,
it takes whatever ruthlessness we can
attach any number of adjectives to Mr.
Johnson anyway,
and it's much more economic style
of writing uses only one phrase.
And that is enough desk completely
adequate for Mr. Johnson.
There's no need for any string of
adjectives to be attached to Mr. Johnson,
some Mr [inaudible] that does it all.
Um,
so we can see right away that this is
really Hemingway's way of both paying
tribute to a generic type. In this
case, we'll Richman, you know,
even his name is generic. Mr. Johnson. Um,
here's a generic type is a
generic Richman who managers,
um, you know, to, uh,
get to be where he is by what he
does by doing so numbers of things.
And he's very, very good
at that. Uh, so once again,
this is a generic type of
specimen of a generic type.
Those so good at what he's doing
that he's stretches the limit,
that type
one a example.
And this one is much more analogous
to the expression, some nigger.
Um, we know that, um, actually
even in Cuba, there's a very,
uh, significant, even in Havana
now there's a very important, uh,
Chinese population and it to tell that
there is a timeless character into have
and have not. Um, he's very
smooth. Talkings looking, uh,
China man.
Um,
he wears a white suit and the silk shirt
with a black tie and a $125 Panama hat.
So he also talks like this.
Um,
and Hemingway gives us a
specimen of the spiritual,
have them have this
very classified or type,
he talks like an Englishman quite.
So it's the things that,
how many you might have fortunate
compared with. Could you both accommodate?
You Mean Carrie?
You stood up and I watch him go out.
Frankly smiled at him. I, he,
when Mr Sam doesn't look at him,
he was a smooth looking
chink. Alright. Some Chin.
Okay. So once again, um,
there's a type that outperforms the
tape by the way of margin, right?
So this is about what kind of performance
can be expected within a generic title
and the extent of that outperformance,
even as a smooth talking
Ching Mr Sing is very,
very memorable. Um, and we see it.
Um,
and even when Mr Sing is that he's still
memorable and still more than just a
specimen, you guys
probably know, um, that um,
Mr Sing is killed by Harry.
Um, because he was Harry,
he was basically the kill off
12 channels, passengers, uh,
that he has no intention of shipping to
where they thought they were going. Um,
so he was Harry to kill those 12 times
passengers and instead of killing those
swells, Chinese passengers,
herring kills Mr. Sing,
but not without a lot of resistance,
a very heroic resistance,
uh,
never seen resistance from Mr
Singh. And this is the outcome. Uh,
his dad is killed by Harry,
uh,
but he's left a mark on herring.
Um,
and this is actually the beginning
of the bodily injuries sustained by,
um,
this is actually one of the structural
principles and the novel is the things
that eat into Harry's body.
And that is pilot with a
catalog of things that,
that we can put on the half not calling
Harry's stars with these of able body
person who is completely his eyes by the,
um,
and he gradually loses some
positive as his body positive.
There's barley,
we get them.
And so is the first instance of something
that happens to his body and is coming
to him because Mr Saint,
I held a wheel with my knee and opened
up my should and saw where Mr Sing did
me.
It was quite a bite and put iodine on it.
And then I sat there staring and wondering
whether the bite from retirement was
supposedly as hell know that bite
wasn't poisonous. A man like that.
And it's the same Polly's from his
teeth two or three times a day.
Some of this to say this is
Hemingway writing and not father,
but we see this thing mixture of cash
and even comedy right here in food as
Flint. So it is not a great
experience to be bitten by anyone.
And this seems to be a very bad,
but um,
but the is also an
occasion on what a generic,
smooth looking chink with deal.
Um,
he's going to be brushing his
teeth three or four times,
then you can count on his hygiene to
save you from getting any infection from
his bike. So this one consoling fat. Um,
but he's at least if you have to be busy
in his belly to be bitten by the lights
and this saying than to be by someone
else. Um, that is the dark comedy,
um, that, um, is emerging
and to have and have not. Um,
but it also is a meditation,
um,
really on all those derogatory labels.
Um,
and the question to us,
uh,
as to whether or not we should consider
them aloud or whether or not we should
say this is an instance where
it is completely legitimate
to use those words or
whether we still think that some
other work would have been preferred.
So I encourage you to talk
about this issue in section. Um,
but now,
um,
I like to switch to part two of two,
half and half,
not um,
and to the possibility
that Harry Morgan himself,
my actually they portrayed as a Tyler,
uh,
as dramatize, uh, and
reinforced by having ways,
narrative technique.
So we're switching to third
person narration and a very
jolting outside view of
herring Morgan.
And this is also the moment when the
black character and actually acquires a
name and sorry,
Wesley,
the man's led by God to steer
you. Treat a man, know about her.
The dog to Negro said
it was getting ugly now,
but the man was still sorry for him. I'm
going to make you comfortable, Wesley.
He said, you just lay quiet.
You ain't going to things me up.
The neighbors had the man
whose name was Harry Morgan,
said nothing then because he liked the
nigger and there was nothing to do.
Now I hit him that he couldn't hit him.
Um,
it is um,
very almost things to add to deliberate
hostility against his own character.
Um,
after so many pages when we're inside
the head and inside the skin of Harry
Morgan two and counter that phrase,
the man whose name was Harry mortgage,
it can be more externalizing and that
can be more objectifying than that.
What is interesting is that
that objectified discretion
is actually use for a
white protagonist in the same moment
when the black character is acquiring a
name like so this kind of double
dynamics suggest that this is a very,
very important moment.
New Black character acquires and them
and the white character also acquires a
name but in a bad way he had,
if when he had been telling the story,
he doesn't refer to himself as Harry
Morgan for the white character to acquire
the name and to be referred to as
the man whose name was Harry Morgan.
Cause him in almost exactly the same
structural position as the black man
Westlake.
Each of them requires a name except the
full of black heritage row to apply and
then is a good thing.
Whereas for the white
character [inaudible] name is
about the worst thing that
can happen to him at that moment.
Um,
why is it that Hemingway was
suddenly switch to this third person?
They're Asian and it's very alienating
mechanism that has been visited upon
Harry Morgan. Um, we can think
of a number of issues. Um,
in section,
in part one we sort of know,
uh, Harry does for a living, right? You
know, we sort of have our, you know,
why does this man have a boat? Uh,
we sort of have our conjectures,
but insect in plug to all of
that is being clarified for us.
Um, we know that the, the
black man is his shot. Um,
and um, there's the smell
of the maker of the boat.
The boat itself is referred
to as the booze boat.
So we know that's what Harry
does in his day smugglers.
They are into the United States.
Um,
he becomes just that, you know,
that's his profession. Um,
and that's what we know him by.
Um,
that takes over to intimate into hurdle
view that we had of him in part one.
And because that is their occupation
that lands him in this type,
in this very tight spot
with his companion. The
black man was maybe in shot.
And we also know that
something else happens as well,
that that Wesley is not the only one,
um,
to be shot on that occasion.
Um,
as we find out in this
man's, uh, disruption.
Who the hell Sean was,
he asked him,
you only you sharp.
Worse than legal side,
but he never been sharp. I didn't
figure it out. You get shot.
I am paid to get shot.
I don't want to be a shot.
[inaudible] Wesley,
the man told him.
Don't do you any good to talk like that.
I'm just this one little
detail that in fact,
both of them were shot,
uh,
because they obviously had run in
the booze world was discovered.
Um,
and so it was a major event,
um, with casualties, um,
in both Harry and Westley.
So far,
whether it's in the foreground,
in part two is the casualty is to,
wouldn't sustain by Wesley. And that's
what he's complaining about. His making,
everyone aware that he's been shot.
The extent of Harris one is
revealed to us in this very oblique,
very marginal mention who the hell
shot worse he asked you or meet you,
your shoppers.
So Wesley and knowledges that actually
the more serious one is on herring,
but we don't actually know
what the consequences might
be because right now the
limelight Israeli aren't Wesley.
And the fact that his furious
for having gotten shot, uh,
for going on this trip with Harry
and Harry trying his best to appears,
um, due to a Westley. And then in the
rest of the [inaudible] two, we also have,
um, this outside character, uh,
federally Harrison who
takes up a louder space,
impart to a one inch report,
Herrick to authorities. Um,
so two is in many ways, um, uh,
part of the story in which we see Harry,
um,
as someone who should be reported to
the authorities or someone who is the
recipient of complaint from,
of bill will of anger out of the glove
at the very leaders from Wesleyan. Um,
and who's also someone that an outsider
would want to report to the authorities.
Um, here's someone who's doing something
illegal. Um, and his, you know,
he's outside the law anyways.
Um,
so all that suggests that it
is fitting that in thought to,
um,
the storage to be tall from outside of
his point of view that we're no longer
inside skin.
We just see him as he is seen by other
people as he's seen by Wesley as he seen
by Captain Willie,
tries to protect him as he's seen
through the by nodular is, uh,
by Federal Harrison who wants to report
him. Um, so he really is an object,
isn't seen object.
Um,
and it's fitting that this thin object
should be conveyed to us through the
third person. Erasion and I think
that there's also another reason,
um,
why Hemingway w one two switch from
first person erasion too verbose in the
Asian,
is that already in part two?
We're beginning to see assymetry between
Harry and the black man as the rain.
We just saw that both of them
acquire and name in part two.
We now see in this moment
that they're also linked.
They are kindred. In one sense,
they're kindred in a narrative sense.
Um,
in the same way that Benji,
Quentin and Jason are
kindred in narrative.
Sam's as authors on these two are kindred
in a narrative sense because the same
thing happen to them being shot.
That is the time between those black
character in this way character.
Um, and it, the only difference
between them, Ashley,
is the degree of severity of that shot.
And here as they, we know that, um,
it is the black man who actually
has the later one that is the white
protagonists who are suffering
the, the, the, the, the worst. Um,
the suffering more actually
on this occasion. Um,
so both the commonality between the
white character and the black heritage or
we'll it or line and
differentiation in the standards.
That is the person who has delay the
one who's been taken care of by Harry,
um,
less than go to chapter nine,
which is in pods free. Um, and here,
um, it is, this is a chapter
that is taught by our,
the very marginal character. Um, so, um,
it is tour from um,
Albert's point of view,
but Harry is once again
seen from the outside.
He is a here in chapter nine
in blood three tap tonight.
There was also interesting
about part three,
chapter nine is that it bears,
the curvy is a revisiting of earlier
moment between Harry and Wesley.
And now we know the consequences
of that gunshot wound earlier.
What happened to your arm?
The lawyer as Harry Harry has to
sleeve and up to the shoulder.
I didn't like the look of it,
so I cut it off. Harry told him,
you and who else cut it off?
Me and a doctor cut it off.
I think that Hemingway really wants
that shock that comes from that lack of
knowledge in section in thought to,
well two goes onto quite awhile and all
the time when reading about Frederick
Harrison,
we have no idea that the one is serious
enough that the arm would have to be
amputated and is the withholding of
that information and what to you that
maximize and said in part three,
it is a shock to us that that is what
will have to happen to Harry and none of
them would have been,
would have been conveyed to us if
Harry had been telling the story.
It is impossible to talk about the
invitation of the loud with this kind of
dramatic impersonality, um,
that Hemingway is ending for.
If it had been told from Harris point of
view, it would have been about his pain.
But Hemingway is not into
conveying to insight view of pain.
That is not a phenomenal field
that he chooses to enter.
Some other novelists do great job within
that phenomena will feel pain that is
not having waste chosen subjects.
Where he was is to give us
that complete impersonal,
neutral,
almost joking,
kind of look at someone losing his arm.
Um,
and that can only be achieved by
looking at Harry from the outside.
So the combination of the straightforward
third person duration impala two and
then Albert telling the
story in part three,
chapter nine,
the combination of those maximizes the
shock of realizing that really hairy is
starting to do something.
He's starting is well on his way and this
trajectory to us to have nod category
his well on his way or losing
one's arm is, is, is, is um,
is, is quite different from losing lots
of other things, uh, to say the least.
So,
um,
we've just seen that Harry has
something in common with Wesley,
but we also see that he has something
ours in common with someone else as well
because of course then when Ellis
pride it is had also lost his mom,
Mr Sing in the fight between Harry
and his to say Harry tries to Ben,
Mr Singh's arm behind him.
And at one point he just,
here's this funny low noise that is
made when an arm is broken. Um, and the,
he lets go there mom, because um,
isn't good to Mr. Sing gang war.
So we've seen that dramatize rendition
of someone losing his arm and this
deliberately on dramatize rendition of
someone losing his arm and only appearing
as a man without,
for Harry to appear as a man without a,
and I'm in the eyes as seen
by the doctor but by a lawyer.
So once again is Harry as a CNR object
but still the common ground is there.
He and Mr saying Ashley, do
you have something in common?
Mr Saint loses his arm,
he loses his life. Um, Harry
loses his arm with a knife,
is going to lose this live like
Mr Sing is to open question,
um, in to have and have no, so
this is a novel that Ashley,
it is very hard to predict
the and they use novel.
So I'm very happy not
to tell you the ending.
I just leave it as an open question.
Um, to what extent is the cemetery, um,
between Harry and Mr Saint go into
extended, how far does that example, um,
but just one more,
um,
meditation on the question
of having and not having,
um,
it seems that Harry actually is quite
aware that he is on his way to becoming a
have not,
but he has his own way
of classifying himself.
So this is one characters,
the term to classify himself in his own
fashion and what is going to be used as
the criteria for classifying
the house and have no,
you can classify people by the amount
of money they have or you can classify
them by whether or not they have arms or
you can classify them by something else.
So here is Harry proposing to
classify himself and his own fashion.
The hell with my arm. You
lose an arm, you lose an arm.
There's worse things than to lose an arm.
You've got two arms and you've got
to have something else. And the,
they were mad with one arm on one
of those to how with it he says,
I don't want to talk about it.
Then after a minute he says,
I got those other two still.
So this is the celebrated concept
of the colonialist that um,
that, that Harry, uh,
still has the word that
having ways very fun of, um,
and uh, that's how he would like
to pacify himself. You know,
maybe the arm is the most
obvious thing that people see,
but the most obvious thing is not actually
the thing that best classify someone.
Um, something that is invisible,
um, could be a better classifier.
So,
um,
I think that the novel entertains that
question is how much can you lose?
You know, the Harry is going to lose a
lot of things in the closet is novel. Um,
you can keep on losing a lot of
things and still remain yourself.
At least that's the hope. Or
maybe that's a fantasy. Um,
we have to decide whether
it's a legitimate hole,
a real or hope that actually is,
has some grounding in reality or whether
it's just a fantasy, uh, weather.
So important when you've lost so much
that you really have stopped being
yourself, you're no longer what it used
to be. Whether that is indeed the case.
So we'll come back, um, and
um, and ramp up the novel,
but thing more about
where we should put Harry.